il n'est jamais trop tard pour agir
contre la pollution plastique juger qui
est trop tard c'est défaitiste et
considéré qu'il faut laisser le
phénomène s'amplifier auront sait que
ces impacts sur le climat sur la
biodiversité sur la santé humaine sont
particulièrement dramatiques donc ne
serait-ce que pour cette raison là ne
baissons pas les bras et agissons contre
la pollution plastique il y a ce qu'on
voit c'est-à-dire qu'en France on est
peut-être habitué malheureusement avoir
un certain nombre d'objets en plastique
traînés dans l'environnement que soit
dans nos rues ou dans l'environnement
naturel et la pollution plastique n'est
pas que ça c'est aussi la pollution par
les microplastiques qui est beaucoup
moins visible et qui envahit les océans
et d'ailleurs tous les milieux
terrestres puisque on en trouve dans les
océans on en trouve en haut des
montagnes on trouve dans les soldes dans
les rivières et on voit bien que les les
origines de la pollution plastique dans
un pays tel que la France n'ont pas du
tout être les mêmes que celles d'un pays
africain qui va recevoir des déchets qui
lui sont envoyés en masse et la France a
d'ailleurs porté un certain nombre de
lois pour agir en la matière elle doit
aujourd'hui essayer d'entraîner le plus
de pays dans le monde dans la communauté
internationale pour suivre sa voie
l'enjeu c'est de savoir comment on
réussir à embarquer 175 pays dans ce
traité international ils vise trois
objectifs le premier c'est de dire que
la pollution plastique ce n'est pas
uniquement ce qu'on voit dans les océans
que la pollution plastique c'est tout au
long de la chaîne de vie des plastiques
de l'extraction du pétrole jusqu'à la
gestion des objets en plastique
lorsqu'ils arrivent en fin de vie et le
troisième grand principe porté par le
traité international c'est celui de dire
que la gestion de la pollution plastique
c'est pas uniquement la gestion des
déchets et donc le recyclage et avant le
recyclage on a la réduction le réemploi
la réutilisation ce qui compte aussi
c'est donc la réduction de ces
plastiques et quand on parle de
réduction en cible notamment les
emballages plastiques à usage unique et
notamment ceux qui aujourd'hui ne
servent à rien on a tous cet exemple en
tête de l'orange vendue sous plastique
et plus chers
n'a toujours réussi à consommer des
oranges il faut désormais que ce traité
international arrive rapidement son
horizon temporel c'est début 2025 qu'il
faut désormais que l'ensemble des pays
réussissent à s'accorder à trouver des
points de convergence pour arriver à
cette traiter international
juridiquement contraignant pour mettre
fin à la pollution plastique pour éviter
que la planète ne devienne comme elle
est aujourd'hui une poubelle à ciel
ouvert